Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton  literally ran away into a pickup truck  and sped away when a process server  showed up to hand him a subpoena so for  people who may or may not know how this  works when you are sued or subpoenaed a  process server shows up and gives you  the paperwork uh identifies who you are  and gives you the paperwork Ken Paxton  the Attorney General of Texas who  presumably understands how subpoena's  work and understands due process and how  Law and Order works when the process  server showed up Paxton ran into a truck  that his wife was driving and they sped  away  this stuff is beyond parody guys